so we've been in the topic of
integration for a while now and what
we're looking at here is a part of the
reference sheet which encapsulate it's a
lot of the knowledge and skill that
we've been developing so alongside all
of these derivatives that you can see
down here this is you know here's the
product rule this is the chain rule you
have the quotient rule over here and
you've also got all these equivalent or
parallel statements about integrations
so you know how to differentiate a trig
function like sine X well this is what
happens when you integrate something to
do with sine X and the result that you
get now there's this result on this page
that are you need to know how to use and
you have been shown it but I want to
explain it in a little more detail
because even though a lot of people know
how to use it or at least produce it in
a question a lot of people don't
understand it and it's this result down
here to do with logs so to explain what
I mean I want us to come back to the
fact that differentiation and
integration they're obviously related we
kind of introduced them as reverse
processes but we've already explained a
little bit about how they're not exactly
reverse processes there's a simple
example of this if you differentiate
something like x squared we know that
that goes to 2x but if we were trying to
undo that process if we were integrating
2x with respect to X we would expect to
get something like X square we would
expect to reverse this process and we do
but we note that when we have to think
about the primitive function there's
actually a bunch of different functions
that could all differentiate into 2x we
could have had x squared plus 1 or x
squared minus 5 or you know x squared
plus who knows a million anything could
have actually within this family have
differentiated to give us 2x and so we
sort of encapsulate that by adding on
what we call the constant of integration
so this plus C indicates it could be you
know the plus one or the minus five or
the plus a million whatever constant
that you like so differentiation and
integration they're obviously really
tied together everything we know about
integration so far has come from our
knowledge of differentiation but there
are some very subtle two
distinctions and one of them has to do
with when you're thinking about
logarithmic functions so let's dive into
this a little further when we
differentiate a function like say log X
the natural log so we've got a base a
here one of the results that we showed
before is that it's equal to one over X
but and then whether it's usually where
we stop but we do need to remember that
that's not exactly completely accurate
and you can see why by drawing a quick
graph of this and seeing what's going on
if I have a think about what log X looks
like it's a curve that looks something
like this this is a very very rough
sketch of y equals log X and when we
think about what the gradient function
of this will be what the derivative will
be well it makes sense that we do have
this part of the graph here of 1 over X
because you can see here that if I have
a look at this graph the entire section
here everything you can see in log X
it's an increasing function but not only
is it increasing it's it's very steep
over here so it's very the gradient
function is very positive and as you go
progress further along the graph as x
increases you have a very shallow
gradient here it's still positive but
it's it's a smaller value so that's why
you can see the gradient function
dropping down like this so that's why we
would say this derivative here dy on DX
it does match 1 over X and we've
actually shown in the past that it
doesn't just look like that it is
exactly that but importantly it's not
the entire graph of 1 over X because
there's actually a section of 1 over x
over here that I haven't drawn 1 over X
the hyperbola it also includes a section
that looks like this but of course that
is irrelevant to the log curve because
the long curve doesn't exist in this
section over here it has a domain
restriction on it it only exists on the
right-hand side and so in fact a more
accurate way to say this is that the
derivative of log X is a specific part
of 1 over x namely that part where X is
greater than 0 now this is very
important this domain restriction
because it means that if I'm trying to
reverse this process if I'm trying to
integrate
1 over X DX it will equal log X plus our
constant of integration but only in this
particular domain over here only 4x is
greater than 0 so if you start in this
section then you'll end up with log X
now this is important to keep to one
side because if I now consider sort of a
very similar function the log of
negative x ok well what do I get from
this I can use chain rule in this case
I've got an inside function which in
this case is negative x so I need to
consider the inside derivative and
thatin that would be negative one in
this case and then I divide by the
inside function now which is negative x
it doesn't see take too much to see that
simplifies to one over X and immediately
this makes a sort of confused because
you're sort of like wait hold on a
second I got 1 over x over here and
somehow I have the same derivative even
though I'm clearly starting with a
different function over here then I had
in the first place how can it be the two
different functions have the same
derivative well the answer lies in what
we're thinking out before with this
domain restriction what does the log of
negative x what does this function look
like well when we slap a minus sign on
the front of the X there the effect is
that we have this horizontal reflection
and what does log of negative X look
like it looks just like the log X curve
except for the fact that it's been
reflected across the y-axis that is to
say horizontally now let's have a look
at this guy what can we say about its
gradient function well for the entirety
of its domain here you can see that it's
a decreasing function and not only is it
decreasing but it starts off kind of
shallow so you're gonna have small
negative values for the gradient here
and then as you progress further and
further closer to x equals zero it gets
very steep so you're gonna have very
negative values so in other words and
that exactly matches all we
for this other part of the hyperbola so
what we have here is 1 over X as we saw
up here by thinking about Oh what
happens when we differentiate but
importantly we have a particular section
of 1 over X namely that section where X
is less than 0 so there's this domain
restriction happening there ok so now we
can say well if you're integrating 1
over X DX
following what we've seen up in this
section up here you might not end up
with log of X you might actually end up
with log of negative X plus the constant
of integration if you are starting with
in a different domain if you're starting
with X is less than 0 okay now what I
want to do is take these two ideas
together and try and fit them into one
because when you have a look on the face
of it this is quite confusing you're
like well if you integrate 1 over X DX
you might end up with one of two things
depending on what domain you're
interested in so now if I sort of
followed these both into 1 let's take
this integral and this integral if I say
you've got 1 over X and you're
integrating that with respect to X you
might equal to well you might equal to
one of two things and I can include both
of them in this statement you might end
up with log X plus C if you are in this
X is greater than 0 domain restriction
alternatively you might end up with log
of negative x plus your constituent
agression if you're all in this X is
less than 0 domain now this is really we
we don't have so far anywhere we haven't
met any functions that do this and kind
of go to either one primitive or a
completely different primitive based on
their domains and this is weird and
awkward looking if only there was a more
concise way of being able to say if you
start with this one thing it's defined
as two different things based on what
your domain is and conveniently there is
notation for this we do have an idea
that matches this when we want to say
something is positive if you
value is positive and then you take the
negative of it if your value is negative
this is exactly what we call the
absolute value of X that's what it is by
definition we would say just putting
over here to the side the absolute value
of X is equal to sum' times X you know
provided that X is greater than zero if
you have the absolute value 5 the
absolute value 5 is just 5 because 5 is
greater than 0 but sometimes the
absolute value of x is negative x if the
value of x that you're putting in is
negative the absolute value of negative
4 is going to be negative of negative 4
you just get 4 and that's because
negative 4 is less than 0 so you can see
I have taken these two domains and I've
kind of collapsed them into one and we
can generalize this further we can say
if we are integrating anything which
looks like f dash on F with respect to X
that is the log or the natural log I
should say of f of X provided you put
those absolute value signs around and
this brings us full circle this is the
result that I was saying to you appears
on the reference sheet and a lot of
people will kind of just pair it off
this absolute value of x section over
here without knowing why where does it
come from this result it comes from the
fact that when we differentiate we can
actually see these two parallel results
here for a positive domain and here for
a negative domain therefore both of
these results will be valid primitives
from this original integrand depending
on well what your domain is so that's
what I want you to take away from this
that this absolute value sign here
doesn't just appear by magic out of
nowhere it comes from what we know our
established knowledge of differentiation